we're going in three two one
[Music]
let's go get this son of a hi
everyone it's Charlie hopefully you've
had a chance to see Avengers end game
and maybe you've seen it a couple times
by now but these are gonna be all about
what happens at the end of the film and
all the scenes during the movie that
tease Marvel phase four movies some
stuff we already know about and some
stuff we learned about for the first
time after seeing endgame if you're new
to the channel be sure to subscribe to
get all the Marvel videos there's a new
round of that Infinity Gauntlet giveaway
all you have to do to enter is be a
subscriber and leave an Avengers comment
on the video big reminder to that next
week we're gonna get a brand new
spider-man far from home trailer
supposedly there's gonna be a special
spoiler warning for the events of
Avengers endgame at the beginning of
that because based on what the Russos
and everyone's saying apparently there's
gonna be some really big universe
changing stuff happening during that
there are 13 different scenes and
teasers on my list here during the movie
they're probably more than that but I
tried to do the ones that we know have
been confirmed for Marvel phase 4
projects these also just go from
beginning to end of the movies so
starting the beginning number 13 Hawkeye
training his daughter Lila Barton in
archery calling her Hawkeye a good job
Hawkeye they high-five each other we
know that they're developing a Hawkeye
series for the Disney Plus streaming
service whether or not they do the Cape
Bishop character or they actually do his
daughter as his successor there's going
to be someone that he trains to take up
the mantle of Hawkeye if you haven't
read the Matt Fraction Hawkeye run
they're probably gonna use that as the
basis for whatever the plot is but
obviously thought to change a couple
things because this Hawkeye is married
he has a family Hawkeye in the comics
did not so it was a very different plot
so just imagine a couple minor changes
to account for those things number 12 a
little bit later in the film Black Widow
asks a coy way about a very big
underwater earthquake off the coast of
Africa around the place where that Iron
Man 2 Namor Easter egg map location was
I don't think I want you looking at that
I'm not sure pertains to you anymore
now this on the other hand as Agent
Romanovs assessment of you if you don't
remember at the end of Iron Man 2 during
the mid credit scene there was a scene
teasing the Avengers initiative because
it was before the Avengers movie had
happened where Ironman is reading Nick
Fury's evaluation of him textbook
narcissism funny moment but in the
background there's a map with a couple
locations one
was teasing Wakanda because we hadn't
gotten Black Panther yet the other was
right near it off the coast which was
teasing Atlantis and Namor Kevin Feige
has said in the past that they're trying
to figure out where and when they would
do a name or character in the MCU but it
is on their minds they do have problems
with the rights to do a Namor solo film
but it's actually pretty easy to put him
in someone else's film so maybe he winds
up being a villain in Black Panther 2 or
some other MCU movie number 11 Ant Man
meets his teenage daughter Cassie Lang
who's obviously still a teenager at the
end of the movie in 2023 during the last
ant-man in the wasp film a younger
version of Cassie says that I want to
grow up to be just like my dad a
superhero but he said he wants you very
clearly teasing that at some point they
would pay off Cassie Lang stature from
The Young Avengers comics so maybe they
do that during the ant-man at the wasp
sequel also back up there a couple Young
Avengers teasers during the movie Cassie
Lang stature is just one of those number
10 Captain Marvel says during the film
she has some friends quote unquote that
might know where Thanos is hiding out
early in the film then for the duration
of that five-year time jump she's
increase crawl space just continuing to
police that part of the universe even
though Kevin Feige has said that they
plan on making Kamala Khan miss Marvel a
character in present day that
present-day means after the events of
Avengers endgame and there's still too
much untouched history between the
mid-90s of the Captain Marvel movie in
the snap during 2018 so I don't think
they're just gonna wave their hand past
all that untouched history when Captain
America says we get it this space is
more your territory it also kind of
implies they intend on keeping most of
Captain Marvel solo films based around
characters from other planets like the
scrolls they can also introduce any
other big space-based characters they
want to during her movies in addition to
the guardians of the galaxy movies which
as of right now are the only real space
franchises that they have in the MCU
number 9 obviously more scrolls Kevin
Feige also revealed recently that
they're definitely evil scrolls in the
MCU who would perpetrate a secret
invasion plot which is his way of saying
that even though the scrolls of the
Captain Marvel movie were good in
we didn't go for Secret Invasion this
time we're definitely gonna use that
story for a future movie but that is so
big that that is an Avengers level story
so just think Avengers secret invasions
sometime in the future that's also
another easy way to bring back dead
characters like Black Widow Ironman
older characters like Captain America
looking young again if they don't want
to save those twists for Secret Wars
number eight the ancient one tells Bruce
Banner about changing the past and
creating alternate timelines there are
several instances where they change the
past but do not go back and fix it those
alternate timelines they created are now
alternate realities where events play
out differently in the last couple of
years characters that are dead an end
game might still be alive in those
realities
Loki with the tesseract is a really good
example that multiple realities is also
the backdoor teaser to Avengers secret
Wars but before they can do something
like that
there are several threat levels in
between like Avengers versus the
Celestials Avengers versus collectivism
to secret war storyline so give them a
hot minute to work up to Avengers secret
Wars like Avengers 7 but also Loki with
the tesseract remember they confirmed
that there's gonna be a Loki series
during Marvel phase 4 they could use
Loki with the tesseract in the alternate
reality as the basis for that series 7
now the time-travel is a pretty common
thing in the MCU that's the backdoor to
king the conquer probably the most
infamous of time-traveling Marvel
villains they can use them anywhere they
want in any big Avengers movie but he
was a pretty notable Young Avengers
villain for a Kate Bishop Cassie Lang
stature two of the characters that they
teased during avengers endgame so no
point in burning him on some other a
lesser film I feel like he would be
great in a young Avengers film if they
want to continue to use time travel as a
story device 6 Black Widow and Hawkeye
referenced Budapest again on their way
to Vermeer making this the fourth or
fifth time that they joked about what
happened in Budapest if they don't at
least do something with that during the
Black Widow prequel movie I will be
pissed because it just seems like a
really easy slam-dunk reference to pay
off
even if Budapest isn't a major part of
the plot of that film 5 when Captain
America goes back in time to live with
Peggy Carter the ruse
for my alternate reality timeline theory
but they also said that the things that
they do together in the past in that
timeline might be covered in a new story
Kevin Feige and Marvel have already
confirmed that one of the Disney Plus
streaming shows is gonna be a what-if
series covering what if Peggy Carter got
the Super Soldier Serum and what if
Steve Rogers had worn an Iron Man suit
built by Howard Stark but the important
thing to note is is that's just one
episode of the what-if series so I don't
know if they're gonna do multiple
appearances from those characters during
that or phobia like a one-off with Chris
Evans but just to be clear they're not
talking about them doing a movie with
those characters for speaking of Captain
America Falcon becomes Captain America
kind of at the end of the film with the
shield obviously they're gonna cover
that during an Avengers sequel but they
have not confirmed what the time period
of the Falcon Winter Soldier Avengers
spin-off series is going to cover only
that it would follow their adventures
when they're not hanging out with the
other Avengers characters if they set
the Falcon Winter Soldier TV series
after the events of endgame then they
can sort of follow up on what Falcon
does the minute after he gets the shield
like how does he handle this does he
start designing a new suit I'm not
expecting them to cover that too much
because Falcon as Captain America feels
like a really big twist that they would
just roll out in whatever the next
Avengers movie is three even though they
do have an a force moment during that
big final battle against Thanos with
Captain Marvel and the other female
characters the MCU I don't think that
they have huge plans for an A Force
franchise but I do think that it's
always possible to do a Thor Ragnarok
style team-up spin-off with Captain
Marvel and a couple of the other bigger
female MCU characters Civil Wars also a
really good analogy for that too but you
had a lot of Avengers in it so it's
almost like a mini Avengers film I don't
know if they would do something that big
with a Captain Marvel sequel but Kevin
Feige did tease that they would continue
to do team-up movies like that in the
future especially with sequel films
that's why we have as guardians of the
galaxy coming up which is also on my
list here so - Thor joins the guardians
of the galaxy formerly at the end of the
movie for guardians of the galaxy three
as guardians of the galaxy which we
already know will cover the emergence of
Adam warlock is an MCU character he was
a villain when he debuted in the comics
the sovereign are villains at the end of
guardians - when they're create
so it sounds like they'll be fighting
Adam warlock at the beginning of the
film but maybe he'll have a parallel arc
for the younger Gamora
where she's kind of a villain in the
film but kind of good and they try to
win her over so early speculation Adam
warlock storyline follows his comic book
storyline where he becomes more of a
hero later in the story and if they do
more Guardians films maybe Adam warlock
will eventually join the team yes there
was that moment earlier in the film when
say like a four-year-old Morgan stark
crawls out of her tent wearing Pepper
Potts rescue helmet saying that she
likes to go into the garage just like
Daddy saying that you know she has an
inclination for technology the way that
he does even though she's only four
years old they might choose to make her
a successor of Ironman in a vastly
future timeline but she's only four
years old now so there'd have to be some
crazy time jump they would have to
really get into some crazy time-travel
during a young Avengers movie to pull
that off in the next four or five years
so yes they're kind of teasing something
but don't hold your breath on someone
else picking up the mantle of Iron Man
any time soon but number one most
obvious set up at the end of the film is
them setting up the beginning of
spider-man far from home starting five
years later in 2023 with Peter meeting
Ned again post snap and it seems like
based on the other trailers that we've
gotten the rest of the debate team also
got snapped because it seems like
they're all really close to the exact
same age as they were at the beginning
of infinity war after the events of
spider-man homecoming he's like Iron Man
and Thor rolled into one he's no
spider-man what is it with you and
spider-man what he looks out for the
neighbor it has a dope suit and I really
respect him sup dickwad the deal with
the new spider-man far from home trailer
is actually pretty interesting because
the Russos recently said that the
spoiler ban on avengers endgame
should be up on monday because it seems
like tickets for spider-man far from
home go on sale Monday and they're
getting ready to drop another trailer
there's been a report that there will be
a special spoiler warning attached to
the beginning of that trailer not just
out of common courtesy but apparently
there's going to be some really big
stuff going on I've seen a lot of
speculation about multiverse being
teased during spider-man far from home I
don't know if that's true you don't
necessarily need that to do Mysterio
we're set up sinister 6 or any of the
other Easter eggs that we've already
seen in the trailers that we've gotten
not about that in the next couple of
days obviously Game of Thrones is
happening this weekend oh that's usually
what I do Sunday in Mondays so if there
is a spider-man far from home trailer on
Monday then I'll just double up no
worries I'll do videos for all the real
big stuff if you have any big requests -
just to be clear though during Avengers
endgame there were no clear teasers or
setup for x-men characters Fantastic
Four characters and they didn't even
really tease that much about Doctor
Strange because we know there's gonna be
a Doctor Strange sequel during Marvel
phase four what will happen with my
Avengers endgame videos in the next
couple of weeks is we'll start to learn
about deleted scenes that they cut out
of the film so I'll do videos for those
obviously later this summer they're
gonna drop the blu-ray there'll be all
kinds of bonus content more deleted
scenes and alternate things about the
movie that we didn't know so I'll do
videos for that stuff too when it comes
it'll be just like the videos that I did
for Avengers infinity war last summer
so we'll say congratulations to Tugg
Speedman you're the giveaway winner from
my last big Marvel video please email me
on the about page of my channel so I can
get your details click here for both my
Avengers and game Easter Egg videos and
click here for my Game of Thrones season
8 episode 4 trailer video thank you so
much for watching everybody stay awesome
I'll see you guys tonight
[Music]